you know what idea whatever light
I've been occurring around my homie
[Music]
we've seen a lot of field relatives I'm
pretty sure
a question for you do have you ever been
to Nicaragua
nice deflection
okay and on the beaches
[Music]
i-it's so guys we got a debate club
chocolate for you the two main things to
do here or heighten volcanoes like this
one or surf on the coast so debate club
which one's better Gang Gang
[Music]
just got done doing well they're
enjoying in the cell I know they are man
something you should do good dude is
this is it you know DVD out there's of
Captain Phillips we're the [ __ ]
Somali pirates in the video you can
think they're on a yacht they're out
surf and it relax and they're enjoying
their time okay not everybody likes
[ __ ] robbing sea of Piccadilly
[ __ ] diners at 4 p.m. in the
afternoon
somebody fouls that make it difficult
you're the one who [ __ ] spent three
years in first grade so the second is a
lot of senior citizens are cold today
because your sins are super jelly when
they watch King in this thing but they
can't how can snack and shut your trap
they can't ngle dude like a pie if I
sing to you to take a like medication I
walk on mine take all your medicine
alright these little thirst rats want to
know volcanoes or surfing I've never
been in Nicaragua but I hope to go one
day he's not that was Hawaii Maui fellas
that's cool dude I'm with a water bra
don't make me put this jacket back on
please don't
okay well people just died on hiking
volcano see that yeah they're like oh
let's check out the [ __ ] and what do
volcanoes do they explode bro not gonna
happen they have no idea what's gonna
happen so all those people died I forget
where they're hiking I think it's New
Zealand just pop dude his mother nature
surprise party baby you know what I'm
saying that's nature busting bro
it's ovulation baby yeah that's lava
elation it's milk from the lava
yeah breasts uh if you're walking on
somebody's tear dude knit bus about as
far apart of it on you bro that's why
you can see far because you want to
sometime you need to see things from far
away you know and then surf and I don't
know what kind of sharks in the waters
out there area you'll be fine dude I
think you just got a if you see a shark
get out you know and plus dude long
you're not surfing at ninety liar then
you'll be fine dude here's the other
problem thick I look like a seal so
sharks like let's eat that look like an
Easter seal telethon do straight
fundraiser bro dude I I guess with these
guys you just hike with your bro man
that's fine the top what do you mean I'm
saying that be fun dude what is it yeah
their outdoor champions or young men
that are venturing out and learning
about themselves and having the courage
to let see do I think they're gonna get
their [ __ ] degree semester at sea
just like you did dude look I think
these guys will be fine wear a sunscreen
you know and don't pretend each other's
a woman that's my rule but see it's
weird dude the boat starts rocking your
visions all crazy oh yeah I know your
buddy dude chest muscles are just strong
ass tits bro you feel me dude what are
these guys viking hiking or what surfing
I actually like to surf but nobody
thinks you've never been surfing oh I
bid that body
this is surfers body Oh
I did hurt my neck yesterday looking at
some wonderfully ones listening at this
point with the gems these guys they've
gotten missing by now
when was this video submitted hopefully
they're alive let make sure they follow
up with this man they follow up with his
hopefully made to the top of the
mountain they'll say hope they made
thought mountain ripped yeah I think
whoever gets to the top of the mountain
dude wrestles the other yeah yeah but
the other one doesn't get to use any
wrestling moves for like 30 seconds yeah
what people say 55 percent way with
volcano yeah that one yeah and I go
volcano 2d and I ain't afraid to [ __ ]
get out there and sip straight off the
tip of the [ __ ] Dark Lord's
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]